Guten Tag, mein Name ist Geschar. Ich bin hier auf der Station der Diensthabende Arzt und ich bin zuständig für Sie.
Ich möchte zuerst ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen. Danach werde ich über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen. Wie heißen Sie dann?
Ich heiße Sebastian Schmidt.
Sebastian Schmidt.
Ich heiße S.B.B.A.
Und ich heiße S.M.I.D.
Ich heiße S.M.G.
Ich heiße S.M.I.D.
75. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 179.
179. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege zur Zeit so 95 kg.
95 kg. Herr Schmidt, was kann ich trusiteln?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe seit langer Zeit immer solche Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und das brennt so im Hals.
Und ja, das ist ein ganz unangenehmes Gefühl.
Und ich war bei meinem Hausarzt und der hat mir so Tabletten verschrieben,
die gegen die Säure sein sollen.
Aber das hilft irgendwie gar nicht.
Und da muss ich dazusagen, mein Bruder ist schwer an Krebs erkrankt,
der hat Spalderöre an Krebs.
Und das habe ich natürlich Panik, dass ich auch so etwas habe.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich stelle mich jetzt noch mal hier bei Ihnen vor,
dass Sie auch noch mal gucken, was da ist.
Es tut mir leid, Ihre Bruder leidet unter Bauchspeiserdrüse.
Nein, nein, Speiseröhren.
Speiseröhre, du du.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Sie leidet unter Schluckstören, ja, richtig?
Ja, also das Schlucken tut mir weh und das brennt so im Hals.
Sie hat ganz oft Sod brennen.
Und ja, manchmal muss ich auch so ein bisschen aufstoßen.
Ich schlafe schon so ein bisschen mit einem hohen Kissen.
Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dann passiert es nicht so leicht.
Und ja, oft ist mir auch schlecht und ich muss dann auch oft zwischendurch husten.
Und beim husten kratzt das auch so im Hals.
Und es tut eben richtig weh, so hier oben, so direkt hinter.
Hinter Brustbein.
Ja, genau.
Okay, hinter Brustbein, Sie haben Schluckschmerzen.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Ihre Schmerzen durft oder stähnt oder brennt?
Nee, es brennt, also ich würde sagen, es brennt und es ist auch so ein bisschen drücken.
Ja, drücken.
Okay.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Schluckbeschwerden?
Sie haben gesagt, seit langem aber...
Ja, das ist schon mehrere Monate.
Und ich hatte halt gehofft, es würde besser werden mit diesen Tabletten da.
Und das hat aber gar nicht geholfen.
Wann waren Sie beim Hausarzt während dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, das ist hier jetzt so zwei Monate her.
zwei Monate.
Aber diese Medikamente hilft Ihnen nicht.
Das hat nicht geholfen, nee.
Und jetzt wollte ich auch nicht mehr nochmal zu dem Hausarzt gehen.
Ich dachte, ich gehe gleich zu Ihnen.
Okay. Sie spüren auch Sodbrennen und Aufstoßen.
Haben Sie Blähungen oder volle Gefühle?
Ja, also Übelkeit, Übelkeit würde ich sagen, aber Völlegefühle, eigentlich nicht so sehr müde.
Okay, volle Gefühle nicht.
Und in nächster Zeit haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Unwirkulich.
Mir nicht aufgefallen.
Der ja schwimmen wir nicht mal ein bisschen abnehmen würde.
Ich habe ein bisschen viel auf den Rhythmen, aber nee, da ist nichts gewesen.
Okay. Herr Schmidt, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Leider Sie unter Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Nö, das eigentlich nicht.
Verstopfung nicht.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Heiserkeit?
Ja, so ein bisschen. Also dieses Kratzen halt vor allen Dingen, wenn ich dann hüften muss und so, dann kratzt es halt ganz besonders.
Okay. Sie haben auch Hüften. Haben Sie eine Ausruf mit Hüften oder ohne?
Nee, also es ist nicht so, dass das Schleim rauskommt. Nee, das ist nicht.
Okay.
Und Herr Schmidt, leiden Sie an chronischen oder erlischenden Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel,
Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich wohl.
Blutdruck, Bluthochdruck. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Das ist vielleicht schon so fünf Jahre oder so.
Fünf Jahre. Dagegen nehmen Sie Medikamente ein, regelmäßig?
Ja, ich nehme da Ramipril ein.
Ramipril. Wissen Sie die Dosierung und...
Oh, nee. Also ich nehme da halt nur morgens eine Tablette und ja, das ist eigentlich nicht so wild.
Okay. Leiden Sie irgendwo hier andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich war ich bisher immer gesund, deswegen macht mir das jetzt ja so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe genau.
Und haben Sie Fieber nachts Schweiß oder Schütterlfrucht?
Also nachts ist mir total ziemlich oft warm, ja.
Das merke ich, dass ich dann schwitze und was, was ich, die Decke wegmache.
Das passiert mir schon mal, ja.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber.
Ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, ich fühle mich richtig fieberig nicht.
Okay. Und haben Sie auch Herzstohlpän, Herzrasen oder Atemnot?
Nee, das ist ein, jemanden Herz, denke ich mal, ist ganz normal, ja.
Also normal. Sie haben kein Herzprobleme oder Atemnot.
Auch Sie haben keine Atemnot.
Nee, nee, nee. Also dieses Kratzen, das ist, das ist unangenehm, aber das ist keine Atemnot.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Schlaf? Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, ich schlafe nicht besonders gut zur Zeit, ja.
Nicht gut. Haben Sie Probleme beim Durchschlafen oder Einschlafen?
Ja, ich denke mehr so beim Durchschlafen, dass ich dann zwischendurch aufwache.
Und das Gefühl habe ich, ich muss husten und dann kratzt es im Hals und dann denke ich,
ja, stehe ich jetzt auf und trink geschluckt, damit es besser wird.
Und ja, denn wenn jemand dann wieder zur Ruhe kommt, das ist schwer.
Okay, ich verstehe genau. Und, mussten Sie oft zum Klo in der Nacht?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also es ist tatsächlich nur, wenn ich dann aufwache,
also es ist nicht so, dass ich aufwache, weil ich auf die Toilette muss.
Aber wenn ich dann wach bin, dann gehe ich meistens eben, weil ich dann sowieso ein Schluck Wasser trinke oder so.
Und dann gehe ich auch auf die Toilette, aber weil das ist also jetzt nicht so,
dass das der Grund ist, weshalb ich aufwache.
Okay, ich verstehe. Zur Zeit haben Sie oft Durst oder möchten Sie?
Durst? Nein.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich etwas hinterher trinken möchte, damit es weniger wehtut.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auch Störung, Schluckstörung beim Weichernährung, beim Wasser trinken oder etwas trinken oder nur hart?
Also ja, wenn ich nicht gut gekaut habe, das merke ich sofort, ja, das ist sehr unangenehm.
Und ja, und da gibt es natürlich auch bestimmte Sachen, wo ich dann merke,
oh, das kratzt ja schon, also bevor ich es richtig runtergeschluckt habe.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel Schokolade esse, ja, dann habe ich das Gefühl, oh ja, das brennt.
Oder wenn ich starten Kaffee trinke oder so.
Okay, beim Kaffee trinken und so weiter.
Und beim Scharf essen oder gewürzige essen oder fettiges essen?
Nein, das kann ich im Augenblick auch nicht.
Ja, das kann ich im Augenblick auch nicht.
Okay. Oder Ihre Beschwerden nach dem fettiges Essen besonders auftreten
oder haben Sie etwas bestimmter Aufböse bemerkt?
Ja, also fettiges Essen weniger, aber eben schokoladisch schnapps.
Ja, schnapps trinke ich jetzt auch zur Zeit wirklich gar nicht.
Und also da merke ich das.
Und ja, bei Kaffee und eben ja, klar, natürlich, wenn ich etwas ganz Scharfes esse,
aber das vermeide ich schon eigentlich, ja.
Okay, Sie vermeiden Scharfes Essen?
Okay, ich verstehe genau.
Frau Schmidt, wurde Sie schon einmal operiert oder?
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Ich bin ein Mann übrigens, ne?
Herr Schmidt, Entschuldigung, ja.
Ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert oder?
Nein, noch nie.
Nein, okay, das ist sehr gut.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten,
Covid-19 und Influenz?
Ja, also ich bin auf alle Fälle als Kind gegen alles Mögliche geimpft worden
und gegen Covid bin ich natürlich auch geimpft worden, ja.
Und dann, ja, ich arbeite als Schreiner
und da habe ich auch dann zur Vorsicht ne Tetanusimpfung,
halte ich mich mal irgendwo verletze.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Leiden Sie unter irgendeinem Fall hier Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich kann eigentlich alles vertragen.
Ja, alles vertragen, das ist auch gut.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit ins Ausland besonders gereist?
Ja, ich war im Urlaub mal in Österreich
und letztes Jahr mal in Dänemark,
aber also keine exotischen Reisen.
Okay, okay, das ist gut.
Herr Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Ja, also nicht so viel, aber so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag rauche ich schon.
Halbes Päckchen am Tag, seid man, rauchen Sie?
Ja, so seit ich 25 bin.
Seit 25 Jahren?
Ja, naja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also abends trinke ich schon gerne mal ein Bier
und am Wochenende auch mal, wenn es ein gutes Essen gibt, ein Glas Wein, ja.
Und wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, eigentlich auch mal einen Schnaps,
aber das habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit, wie gesagt, weggelassen.
Okay, jeden Abend trinken Sie ein Bier, richtig?
Ja, doch wenigstens ein Bier am Abend, ja, das kann man so sagen.
Seid man trinken Sie?
Oh Gott, seit ich erwachsen bin, ja, seit ich Bier trinken darf.
Seit ungefähr 30 Jahren, okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, bitte, aufgrund medizinischen Gründen stelle ich immer.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen oder rauchen Sie Kalabis oder irgendwelche Drogen?
Oh Gott, das ist so lange her, ja, ich habe das mal probiert,
als ich angefangen habe zu rauchen.
Ja, da habe ich mal, da habe ich auch mal ein Joint geraucht,
aber ja, das war eine ganz kurze Phase in meinem Leben.
Okay, okay, freut mich.
Ja, in Ihrer Familie gibt es irgens welche chronische oder älteren Kranken, die am Backup?
Ja, was ich sage zu meinem Bruder, ne, dass der eben so schwer krank ist
und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen Panik, ne.
Ja, es ist vielleicht ja.
Ja, und mein Vater, ja, da weiß ich nur, dass der auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte tatsächlich jetzt vor gar nicht so langer Zeit ein Schlaganfall,
die hat sich aber ganz gut erholt, die ist schnell in die Klinik gekommen
und die haben sie also gut behandelt und sie hat eine Reha gehabt
und der geht jetzt eigentlich schon wieder ziemlich gut, da ist also nicht viel zurückgeblieben.
Ja, das freut mich. Sie sind voll gut behandelt, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Geschwister außer Ihr Bruder?
Nee, keine weiteren Geschwister.
Keine weiteren. Nur, Sie haben ein Bruder und sie leidet an Speicheröre.
Mein Bruder leidet an Speicheröre an Krebs, ja.
Okay, Speicheröre an Krebs.
Okay.
Und wie behandelt erst, Operativbehandlung oder mit?
Ja, also da ist was operiert worden, da hat er irgendwie so, da ist irgendwas entfernt worden
und geflickt worden und danach hat er, hat er eine Zeit an Chemotherapie gehabt.
Chemotherapie, okay.
Danke, ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schreiner sind.
Ja, genau.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Sohn haben wir ja.
Der ist aber schon ziemlich groß, der ist zwar jetzt noch zu Hause, aber der ist so pflückisch.
Ist er gesund?
Mein Sohn ist gesund, ja, ja, ja.
Danke, mit wem lehnen Sie? Mit Ihrer Frau, oder?
Ja, ja, mit der Familie zusammen, genau, mein Sohn und meine Frau.
Ja, sehr gut, mit Ihrer Frau.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, ich habe keine weitere Frage, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gesteckt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, Sie können natürlich jetzt wissen, was ich, was man wirklich hilfreich dagegen machen kann
oder ob das wirklich ganz sicher nicht so etwas ist, was mein Bruder eben auch hat.
Das ist halt meine große Sorge im Augenblick, ne?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen genau.
Ich bin für Sie da und wir möchten unsere Bestes für Sie.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen natürlich und werde ich Blut abnehmen
und ein paar bildgewende Verfahren werde ich durchführen.
Sie haben einige Risikofaktoren.
Sie haben geraucht und trinken regelmäßig Alkohol
und in Ihrer Familiengeschichte Ihr Bruder leidet an Speiseröhre Krebs
und werde ich ein Özefabogastrodeodonskop oder Speiseröhre Spiegelung durchführen,
Magenspiegelung durchführen um mögliche Erfangen zu...
Muss ich das zum Krankenhaus planen?
Ja, es ist halt für Genaussussagen, wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen,
werde ich Sie darüber informieren.
Ne, aber für diese Untersuchung muss ich dafür im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, für Magenspiegelung, sie müssen nüchter sein.
Jetzt sie, ja sie müssen nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben,
aber wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen, werde ich Sie genau darüber informieren.
Okay, ja.
Okay, gut, danke schön.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie in der Liste seit 2 Jahren bei der GWIT abgenommen?
Hat er gefragt, hat er aber nicht, nein.
Okay, danke.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Welchen Medikament hat Ihre Hausarzt verschreiben?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Es liegt bei mir zu Hause auf dem Ess-Tisch,
aber es hat ja nicht geholfen.
Und wie das hieß, kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Muss ich zu Hause nachgucken?
Nehmen Sie vielleicht andere Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ich nehme nur dieses Blutdruckmittel regelmäßig ein.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Veränderungen in der Stuhlfarbe bemerkt?
Ne, aber da habe ich auch nicht so genau hingeguckt,
aber ist mir nix aufgefallen.
Okay, danke.
Kommt es eher Mundflüssigkeit von den Magen?
Ah, so saures Ausstoßen, meinen Sie.
Ja, genau.
Hab ich gesagt, dass ich das hin und wieder habe,
wenn ich scharf gegessen oder Süßigkeiten gegessen habe.
Auch wenn ich mich hinlege,
wenn ich zu flach liege im Bett.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie mit der Betäubung operiert?
Ich bin noch gar nicht operiert.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, nach dem Schokoladeessen oder Kaffee trinken,
Ihre Schmerzen verschlimmen.
Gibt es etwas, Ihre Probleme oder Ihre Schmerzen verbessern?
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn ich merke, dass das so brennt,
versuche ich halt Wasser zu trinken.
Und das ist eigentlich nur so ein Gefühl, dass da irgendwas gegen angeht.
Und eben, wenn ich nicht ganz flach liege, das tut mir gut.
Deswegen schlafe ich also mit einem zweiten Kissen.
Und haben Sie auch Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen im eigentlichen Sinne eigentlich nicht.
Die Schmerzen sind hier so hinter den Dritten.
Wurde bei Ihnen früher so vorgegastet oder durchgeführt?
Nein.
Geht ja, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Ja, ich kann köstlich sein.
Ich bin so früh dunkel jetzt, ganz strecklich.
Braucht man schon Licht.
Guten Tag Frau Obersten.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz gesagt dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich berichte über den 50-jährigen Patienten
Herrn Sebastian Schmid, der 95 Kilogramm liegt
und 1,79 Meter groß ist.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns,
und hat sich in der Mitte von einem Monat 5
einen Retrocheternail aufgenommen.
Und das ist der Patient.
Er hat sich dann über die Pirazis aufgenommen.
Pirazis, die Pirazis, die Pirazis, die Pirazis, die Pirazis,
die Pirazis, die Pirazis, die Pirazis, die Pirazis,
Er beschrieb seine Schmerzen als brennend und dürkend.
Er hat wegen dieser Schmerzen eine Medikamente eingenommen.
Jedoch hat die Medikamente keine Linderung geworfen.
Die Frage nach Fieber, nächtliche Superhydrose,
die Frage nach Fieber und Gewichtaufnahme wurden verleint.
Und sie erklackte überall nächtliche Superhydrose.
Er hat auch unproduktive Tusis.
Und unproduktive Tusis.
Fragen nach Arithmi, Tachycardi und Dyskne wurden verleint.
Der Patient leidet unter Nutztweikissen in der Nacht wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Er war schon beim Hausarzt und wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Und der Hausarzt hat eine Medikamente verschrieben.
Aber diese Medikamente hat keine Linderung gebracht.
Der Patient leidet seit fünf Jahren Arterialhypertoni.
Dagegen nimmt er Rami Prill einmal morgens.
Aber die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Für die Operationen wurden fernleinzt.
Er hat Erist von Städtik geimpft.
Er ist unaufwendig und hat keine Anergie oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Er raut seit 25 Jahren ein halbeschachter Zigaretten.
Er trinkt jeden Abend eine Flasche Bier und gelegenlich ein Glas Wein und Schnaps.
Er ist hier konservativ behandelt.
Er leidet an Özephagus Carcinoma.
Er ist wegen Özephagus Carcinoma operiert und mit Chemotherapie behandelt.
Er ist schreiner verheiratet und ein gesundes Sohn.
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am 1.Auf Gastro-Özephagel-Reflexkrankheit.
Was könnte ist differenzial Diagnostisch noch sein?
Der differenzial Diagnostisch ist der Özephagus Carcinoma.
Der Özephagus Carcinoma ist eine Pluritis.
Er ist eine Pericarditis in Betracht.
Er ist in Betracht.
Er wird den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Er wird mit Vitalparameter überwachen.
Er wird mit Blut für das Labo abnehmen.
Wie hoch machten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es vergrößerte Lymphknoten oder Lechadone-Megali gibt.
Im Halsbereich?
Im Halsbereich.
Ich achte darauf, ob es verweiternde Jugendliche gibt.
Erweiterte Jugendliche gibt.
Im Bauch achte ich darauf, ob es Druckdolenz gibt.
Oder Schwellungen, Acides gibt.
Oder Hautveränderungen, Gelbsucht gibt.
Sehr gut.
Ich werde auch ein Özerfabrogastrodenoskopi durchführen.
Um mein Verdacht, dass wir uns bestätigen.
Und mögliche Maginkarsinom oder Ulcus ventriculi auszuschließen.
Was für Laborwerte bestimmen Sie denn?
Ich bestimme großes Blutbild und Entzündungsparameter.
Und Nieren und Leberwerte bestimmen lassen.
Ich möchte ein Atemtest durchführen, um mögliche Helikobacter-Pillory-Infektion auszuschließen.
Sehr gut.
Ich werde auch Folgendetherapie voll.
Protonpompe, Hämmer werde ich verschreiben.
Wenn ein Helikobacter-Pillory-Infektion vorliegt, werde ich Antibiotika.
Ich werde Trippeltherapie verschreiben.
Ich werde den Patient ambulant behandeln.
Was geben Sie ihm für Empfehlungen mit?
Ich empfehle den Patient Lebensstilveränderungen.
Beim Essen Alkohol und Zigarette zu aufzuhören.
Und scharfes Essen, fettiges Essen zu versichten.
Gewichtabnahme ist auch wichtig.
Der Patient ist übergewicht.
Deswegen empfehle ich, Sport zu treiben.
Sehr gut.
Schauen Sie nach Herrn Schmidt und halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Das war super.
Es war eine sehr schöne Anamnese.
Es war ein sehr schöner und schlussiger Bericht.
Ich habe eine winzige Sache, wo ich fragen würde.
Er hat zugegeben, dass er Graf geraucht hat.
Sie haben aber gesagt, Drogenkonsum verneint.
Ich würde sagen, es ist unaufwählig.
Aber ich habe gesagt, es war eine sehr alte Geschichte.
Es ist so etwas, das man vernachlässigen kann.
Das war das eine.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, die Mutter ist in der Familien einmal.
Schön.
Das hat er auch gehört.
Bei der Familienanamnese haben Sie gesagt, die Mutter leidet an einem Apoplex.
Apoplex ist ein Punktereignis.
Oder hat ein Apoplex erlitten.
Hat den aber gut überstanden.
Das ist keine Krankheit, an der man dauerhaft ist.
Der Apoplex ist ein Knaller eignis.
Ich verstehe genau.
Er litt einen Schlaganfall.
Er ist gut rehabilitiert.
Natürlich machen sie grammatikalisch ein paar kleine Fehler.
Aber von mir aus war die Verständigung sehr gut.
Das Einzige, das Sie zweimal gesagt haben, ist eine Medikamente.
Ein Medikament, das Medikament.
Plural das Medikament, die Medikamente.
Er hat eine Medikamente bekommen, das ist nicht richtig.
Er hat ein Medikament bekommen.
Sonst gibt es nichts, was man kritisieren kann.
Das ist super gelaufen.
Ich würde sagen, Sie haben eine perfekte Darstellung gemacht.
Sie haben gesagt, im September haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, am Ende September.
Können Sie ganz entspannt.
Ich bedanke mich dafür.
Vielen Dank.
Wir sehen uns am Donnerstag.